hi my name is Burke and I love user
interface
I've always loved user interface I
remember staring at the glory that was
compact tab works while I played this
game called the incredible machine and
listen to the Tears for Fears greatest
hits album now don't judge me I was
listening to mad world way before that
Donnie Darko in that creepy rabbit movie
that's an old and obscure reference you
may not get that that's okay what I'm
trying to say is it's not you it's me
that's Costanza would say that's another
old and obscure reference you know what
forget all that let's move on I got my
first computer when I was in the
military actually I was in boot camp and
they pay you in boot camp but you can't
spend the money you know because you're
doing push-ups and stuff and so after I
got out of boot camp my dad encouraged
me to buy a computer so I got my first
computer oh you can see this ledger here
which was a compact HP Pavilion it
looked just like this and it came with
Windows 98 all my sounds aren't working
yeah there we go
and I loved Windows 98 I spent so much
time just changing the themes the
different themes looking at the icons
and the text I mean each theme was
better than the previous theme it was
incredible it was so good and if only I
had known then if only I had known what
was coming if only I had known about
Windows XP okay this was do you believe
in love at first sight does love at
first sight exist no of course it does
it no be ridiculous love is a very
complex human emotion but let me tell
you what does exist infatuation and I
was infatuated with Windows XP I mean
the curves on the Start menu the blues
and the greens the way the windows are
layered in space it was beautiful I know
it's weird but I wasn't that socially
popular so I had a lot of time to sit
around and do weird things like stare at
an operating system and then this
spawned a big hacker community and a lot
of tools to ask in Windows XP and when
you can do that obviously you want to
make it look like OS 10 that's the first
thing you do so this one goes out to
startup now as much as I love UI I'm not
a designer as much as I want to be a
designer I am NOT a designer he's a
designer I'm not a designer now what I
can do is assemble building blocks so if
you give me
lighters and dropdowns and modal windows
then I can build you UI and I used to
work for this company called kendo UI
and so I've been fortunate to be a part
of some great UI products but you
wouldn't hire me to build a website for
you ok
unless you were my mom otherwise you're
not gonna hire me to do that that would
be subpar results and so what I've
realized through all of my time working
with UI is that really the best user
experience is is no UI at all so let me
talk about that for a second UI is kind
of a middleman it's a conversation it's
pre-canned and it's it has boundaries
right so we try to code for the simplest
possible scenario to get a user through
the process or all the processes in the
world right and this is so this we could
improve upon this UX probably a little
bit now there's been some great feats of
UX genius I'm still a fan of
skeuomorphic design if a baby can pick
up and use an iPad without any training
you know that's kind of an amazing thing
now that said the reason why we have UI
in these wonderful buttons and sliders
is because historically we haven't been
able to talk to computers until now
natural language processing is the field
of computing that deals with not just
speech recognition but extracting a
user's intent from what they just said
you may be familiar with this in a
couple different forms we have Alexa
Cortana Siri and Google home or ok
Google or Google assistant or whatever
the heck you call that thing a lot of
people have these I'm gonna give you
three examples of how I think no UI is
better than a UI
the first one is creating reminders so I
can say hey Siri remind me to email my
mom and that experience is way better
than going in to the reminders app and
doing this no matter how beautiful the
reminders app is it will never be as
easy as me just saying do it another one
is home automation here's an example of
me turning lights on and off with an
well actually here's the app that you do
it with so here's me turning lights on
and off with the app very nice and now
here's me doing it
Alexa turn off the lights in the master
bedroom now watch this okay Alexa can
you turn on the bedroom turn on the
master bedroom lights and that is
natural language processing right I
completely botched that command seven
different ways and it still was able to
pick it up and do it you know what's
even better is if you have a nest
thermostat you can lay in bed and
control the temperature with your voice
and now that I've said that sounds
really pathetic you know what never mind
I don't ever do that the last example
I'd like to give you as a service called
digit digit is a remarkable little
service that saves for you using machine
learning based on your spending patterns
and it will give you savings updates I
blurred this out so you don't get too
depressed by my low balance and the
whole interface is conversational so it
has an app now but before all you did
was chat with it to save to withdraw and
it was pretty resilient at understanding
my commands I didn't have to know what
to say I just said it and I thought that
that was quite remarkable so the
question now is is UI as we know it dead
the answer is no no absolutely not there
are accessibility concerns you wouldn't
want to activate take photos with your
voice you wouldn't want to scroll
through pictures with your voice right
like scroll up scroll down scroll that
that's not a good user experience but it
does give us a chance to rethink some of
the ways that we build UI is that maybe
we don't need to build a UI and instead
what we need to build is something
that's more conversational in nature
that uses natural language processing
because that's now available to all of
us and if I'm gonna end a little bit
early ooh
several seconds early you can check out
the Luas project here this is a
completely free tool it's a visual
interface you can build and then as long
as you know how to make an AJAX call you
can add natural language processing to
your applications and or build a bot or
a conversational UI thank you so much
you